hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the World Chess Championship
match between Yani polish and English
and this is game 14 and while I say the
final game it only means the final game
if it ends with a win for either players
so whoever wins this game it doesn't
matter that they've already played 13
classical games whoever wins this one is
the world classical Champion if it ends
in a draw then we go into rapid tie
breaks so there's quite a lot to discuss
the game lasted over six hours so let's
dive straight into it the first
ceremonial move was made by this
gentleman here it is Molly Nash the
church person of the Senate of the
parliament of Kazakhstan and he is
pre-moving the pre-moving he's moving
the the black pawn to D5 so I have no
idea what's Happening Here usually uh
whoever makes the first ceremonial move
opens with the white pieces he for some
reason uh replied to dings D4 by by D5
sort of as if ding already played D4 uh
weird weird thing but you know what are
you gonna do so they retracted the moves
and then ding made his actual first move
and that is Pawn to D4 and now everyone
I was wondering what ding will choose
for the final game will we see another
London will we see a nice calm opening
some sort of maybe even a queen's game
but accepted some wild stuff maybe
another names of Indian let's see what
happened with D4 biting Knight to F6 we
have C4 E6 and now Knight the C3 with
Bishop to B4 uh and the names of Indian
is on the board we have Ponte E3 and
here we have Castle so pretty standard
stuff here and now in game eight the one
that the ding almost one had he found
that spectacular Rook to D3 uh lift uh
A3 was played but here we have Bishop to
D2 and now comes Pawn to D5 we have Pawn
to A3 and it's a very well known
position uh alireza felugu headed
against anijigiri for example in the FTX
crypto Cup last year uh and some other
very notable games were played in this
line uh but here we have uh Bishop D7
Knight to F3 with Pawn to C5 now putting
pressure on White Center D captures on
C5 by Bishop characters and now Queen to
C2 just getting the queen on this long
diagonal and now there are a couple of
games that reach this position the most
notable notable one being Alexander
donchenko played against raos
lavoitashek uh where vitashek continued
with knights the C6 and that game ended
with a draw but here we have D captures
on C4 and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so Bishop
captures and C4 grabbing the pawn back
Knight B to D7 by yawn with Rook to D1
now getting the Rook enter game aligning
it nicely with the queen and we have
Bishop back to E7 here you could also
just consider a move like a B6 and
putting the bishop on this long diagonal
but uh Jan prefers to get the bishop
Auto Harm's Way It Is in front in front
of the queen so here just Bishop back to
E7 and now Knight the G5 and ding now
says uh uh this is if this was a normal
game like if you played a game on
leeches or orange juice.com and you're
playing bullet you're playing Blitz you
know okay you're playing a knight to G5
you want to Checkmate your opponent but
you kind of don't expect this approach
in a wheelchair championship match
especially in the final game of the
World Chess Championship match so here
uh Nepal had to figure out what was
happening and he just play H6 and say
okay Move That Knight away from there
that's a silly move uh and he calculated
and he plays it but now ding does not
move the Knight back he plays Ponte H4
and it's not a peace sacrifice or
anything you can't really capture this
Knight if you capture the Knight
captures captures you can't move the
knight from F6 otherwise you're getting
checkmated and this would um be serious
trouble for black so after this H4 move
we have Queen to C7 putting pressure on
the bishop and now ding spent a lot of
time here uh he he spent like 25 minutes
here and he moved the bishop back to E2
and you could also consider Bishop to B3
and this is sort of the main line to
consider because now how do you how do
you play this uh the the point is that
you are threatening Knight to D5 let's
let's say black makes a silly move
you're playing Knight to D5 and now the
queen has to go back because if you
trade Queens white first has a nice
Vision too you're gonna grab the bishop
with Tempo and after King they cheat
Bishop captures on C2 you're gonna be up
a piece the problem is after Bishop to
B3 Nepal can just move the queen to C6
and nothing is really happening here
you're putting pressure on that G2 Pawn
F3 can be played and the game continues
very very sharp uh lines uh you know
possible but ding retreated with Bishop
T2 and the situation on the clock is now
57 minutes for Ding and over an hour and
30 minutes for Nepal so ding again
burning a lot of time here uh also uh
well uh you might be wondering what
about Knights the knights the B8 uh
Knight the B5 then just Queen to C6
again and again nothing spectacular then
I can go back to F3 then the Knight
comes to V6 puts pressure on the bishop
and we get a queen trade Bishop here
Queen characters Bishop capture so this
is also possible but yeah uh E2 and now
comes Rook the d8 by nepo uh and a
crucial continuation here might have
been onto B6 and when I say crucial I
only mean the top suggestion by the
engine the problem is now after B6 uh
how does Dean continue let's say Rook to
C1 uh and now okay the queen seems to be
in a lot of trouble you can play Queen
back to d8 and now after Bishop to F3
attacking The Rook seems like you are
getting a lot for white the problem is
there are all sorts of nasty lines like
Bishop to A6 cutting of the white king
from castling and even if you capture
the rook and A8 there's Knight to the C5
and here white basically resigns so you
have to be very very careful Knights the
uh D3 check is coming there's no good
way to to handle this for example you go
back Bishop to F3 still Knight the D3
with check if King 31 Knight captures an
F2 with check you pick up the Rook on H1
and white is completely busted so that's
why uh here Rook to D it was played
instead
when I say instead I mean after after B6
and this line that we've shown if the
queen now moves the d8 let's say queen
to the eight and Bishop to F3 uh you
don't of course have to play this white
can also just ring the night back and
then the line that we've shown is not
forced but still you you can play it
Bishop to B7 uh and the the game
continues very nicely but the problem is
now that
um uh there's nothing for white here
white just has a silly H4 move in a
position where white should not have an
H4 move so B6 that's why I say it could
have been the crucial line so okay Rook
38 was played by nepo we have Rook to C1
and now Knight the f8
we have knighted G to E4 now getting the
Knight out of Harm's Way uh you could
also play Knight to F3 uh also a fine
idea but then again E5 comes and the
white can't really say that he has
anything for example Knights the D5
there's Knight captures on D5 and if
Queen captures and C7 captures and
captures look scary but there's Bishop
to D6 you attack the rook and once The
Rook moves then Bishop to E6 again
everything perfectly fine for black uh
you know if anything you prefer black
here so that's why 90 G the E4 was uh
tried by the Knight captures on e4 and
now you could play Queen captures on e4
but uh it again it seems like you're
giving black a bit too much Queen to D6
will be played going after the bishop
and after The Rook defends Now Pawn to
F5 and it doesn't look all that
spectacular for white so that's why uh
ding played Knight captures an E4 he
offered the queen trade and the Yan
accepted the trade with Queen captures
Road captures and just Bishop to D7 uh
getting his Bishop into the game and
while you would consider a move like
Rook to C7 it looks pretty good black
will just defend the pawn here and after
H5 there's Rook D to see it and now the
Rook has the trade and after captures
and captures You're Gonna Play Bishop to
C3 put the bishop on this long diagonal
uh so that is uh definitely possible but
you don't really gain all that much with
Rook to C7 all even though it looks like
a great move so uh Bishop to B4 was
played uh offering a Trader Bishops and
nepo takes it uh why not you're gonna
double the spawns here with Bishop to C6
and now Knight the C5 and now not only
does ding have doubled pawns he's also
offering the G2 Pawn in order to gain
some activity for The Rook so it looks
it looks uh very scary to do something
like this in the final game of the World
Chess Championship match the situation
on the clock is 14 minutes for Ding and
an hour and seven minutes for nepo so
again a leading on time Bishop captures
and G2 nepo does take the pawn Rook the
G1 and now Bishop back to D5 just
keeping the
uh Bishop out of Harm's Way again at The
crucial continuation probably was Bishop
to C6 the point being after B5 and it's
very similar to what actually happened
in the game in D4 uh you don't have to
move the bishop you can play B6 that's
the point and now uh this pretty much
forced E Capture some d5b captures and
C5 real captures on C5 uh if you capture
on E6 this is not really Spectacular Now
it captures the C5 Pawn is defended so
the the main thing here is captors here
and then Pawn captures
um uh on on the five and black again
gets the pass deep on uh this would be
uh well very interesting for black to
say the least varca enable played Bishop
to D5 uh now comes E4 by being Bishop to
C6 and pawn to B5 so similar but not
quite as he reversed the move order now
you don't have B6 because it would just
be weird but you're gonna play captures
captures and now Bishop to a six guards
the queening square this is just um lost
for black so that's why after the after
Pawn to B5 Bishop to E8 by nepo uh and
not Knight captures on B7 and okay ding
wins back the pawn uh situation on the
clock is 39 minutes for nepo uh and some
uh uh 43 minutes for for Yan uh we have
rooked the D4 going after the pawn here
Rook to see for defending and now Rogue
back to D7 going after the Knight we
have Knight to C5 now attacks the rook
and Rook the C7 uh also a fine line uh
is Rook to D6 but now if Ponte E5 then
comes Rook to D5 attacking the pawn and
now what do you play here you can't of
course Play Bishop to F3 because Rook
captures an E5 comes with the track so
you're gonna have to play Knights the E4
enough look at this Rook captures on E5
Knights the F6 would check the pawn of
course cannot capture King to each a
knight captures 98 Rook captures and now
Rook the C7 putting pressure on F7 and
on A7 and after King to G8 you have to
defend this because otherwise the pawn
structure gets completely shattered Rook
the G4 you put the Rook um here or or if
black captors you're going to play Pawn
to B4 you will win the A7 pawn and it
you know it's uh it's definitely
possible uh so uh while uh it's it's a
move maybe you're giving white a bit too
much but it can be played uh so Rook to
C7 and now Rook the C3 biting uh we Rook
ate the C8 doubling up on the C file uh
that's why I didn't put put the Rook to
C3 uh and uh also possible is Knight to
G6 this is a very tricky line that
allows Rook captures on G6 but the
problem is even if you allow this real
capture spawn captures a knight captures
on E6 attacking The Rook uh you can't
trade because then you just undouble
white spawns which will be great for
whites you're gonna have to play
something like Rook to D7 then F3 and
the game continues looks very uh tricky
but now black would be the one with the
the shattered Pawn structure you would
have the the double G pawn and white
would be up upon for being down the
exchange so again one of the
possibilities and uh well uh you know
this might be a bit of a longer video as
there are many possibilities in this end
game so Rook a to C8 putting pressure on
the Knight and here uh there are again
many uh ideas you could play you could
play this over the night and now if the
Knight is captured you could just
Checkmate black captors and once you go
here this will just be Checkmate but of
course uh this is not forced once a rook
to G3 is played you can just block with
G6 and then you can defend with B4 so
that's definitely an option another
thing you could do is play this very
tricky Knight the B7 line it's uh what
is this of course The Rook cannot
capture because then the rook and C8
hangs so we're gonna play Rook captures
on c3b captures and Rook captures and
now you're gonna play King D2 just like
that attack the rook and once Rook goes
back Knight to D6 now uh put pressure on
the bishop and once you play Rook the D7
to pin the Knight the Knight isn't going
anywhere now E5 and if F6 Pawn to F4 so
even this is possible uh where you know
it's it's very hard to say what is what
is happening here but the ding instead
after this Rook 8 the C8 move goes B4
right away and now we have a nice Knight
to D7 now we have Rook seat to G3 uh
another another way to approach this
would be not to react right away you
could play King to D2 and now if Knight
captures on c5b captures and Rook
captures you could play Rook G to C1 and
now look at this if Rook captures Rook
captures now you're gonna play Rook to
B8 put pressure on this Pawn here not
Rook to C5 and then the king just comes
uh into the game so uh even this is
possible white would be down upon but
you would get a lot of activity that
black king has has some moves before he
can get it into the game
Rook seat the G3 was played by ding
right away and now it seems like nepo
has to defend here but nepo shows that
and he doesn't have to he just plays
Knight captures on C5 Ding recaptures
and The Rook captures on C5 now ding
does capture on G7 King to f8 and now
Bishop to D3 and what's happening here
uh situation on the clock 21 minutes for
Ding and 25 minutes for Nepal we have
Rook to d8 putting pressure on that
bishop and here we have King the E to
everyone expected King to D2 to prevent
to Rook to C3 but the ding actually
invites it and Nepal goes for it Rook to
C3 so what is happening here where where
can the bishop Retreat there really
aren't a lot of squares well first thing
goes for Rook the G8 checking the E7 and
now Rook one uh Rook won back to G3 to
defend the
uh the uh Bishop here and it's uh the
the problem is this position is
completely wing for nepo but it's almost
impossible to find out why uh there are
four more moves to be made to reach time
control and you of course Nepal was
afraid to burn too much time here and
other than that one line that I've seen
that even the standard engines don't see
a win here but the assessed Norwegian
supercomputer found the winning line
here uh so if you guys want to try if
you can spot the super computer line in
this end game feel free to pause the
video and try to spot this line uh while
I give you a couple of seconds
uh even the engines here like the the
ones that I'm using now at pretty
reasonable depth are not showing the
wind for uh for nipple but there was one
and then this essay uh showed us the way
uh so for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being able to
play the end game like a super computer
yeah and for those of you who just won't
enjoy the show the movies Rook the B3
and now the point is okay obviously we
are putting pressure on this Pawn here
but after white continues with something
like Ponte F4 that doesn't matter this
is what says it considers the be the
best move for white uh Rook to D4 just
increa increasing the uh the pressure
and after Rook to E3 uh Bishop to D7 uh
we have Rook the B8 now uh defending the
pawn but now there's Pawn to A5 and once
this Pawn starts marching down the board
it is pretty much game over but still a
lot to be considered here like Rook to
B7 uh Pawn to A4 will be pushed B6 now
comes A3 Rook to A7 now even rooked A4
this is how you block uh but uh King to
D2 A2 and now even if Rook to E1 you
will play Rook capture some B6 Rook
captures an A4 Bishop captures an A4 and
now Rook to A1 uh Bishop to B3 defends
the pawn and now if Bishop to C2 you
will capture it Bishop captures King
captures and you will play Rook D6 put
the Rook behind the pass pawn and now
whatever white plays uh doesn't really
matter if clicking to B2 if if you trade
Pawns of course the end game is winning
because the black king is so much closer
to the white pawns and if you don't you
play something like E5 to try and hold
the black king or after the black king
still will find his way into the game
there's no stopping this so this is why
it's winning but an apple didn't go for
that he played E5 right away and now
ding is back in the game we have rooked
a trade he goes after the H Pawn uh and
but already is down to nine minutes and
he has three more moves to make the
reach time control we have rooked the D6
uh and he find ding found it here know
where he's there uh Rook to D6 defending
the pawn and now comes a ding's ID upon
on the B6 it looks like a crazy Pawn
sacrifice that does nothing but it
actually forces uh a playable end game
because the ding was very very close to
actually losing here as you've just seen
and if not for this B6 move he probably
I would already be lost so now there's
no way to handle this other than to
capture Rook capture some B6 was played
and now what's the point of doing spawn
sacrifice well Rook captures an E8 of
course with check King captors and
notice that the king is now on a light
Square you have a light Square bishop
and the Rooks are staring at each other
uh of course you know what comes next
the bishop to B5 with check real
characters and now Rook captures on C3
and now we have this rook and pawn end
game nepo is up upon it's a past a pawn
but can he do something with it uh we'll
see King to D7 we have Rook to F3
putting pressure on the pawn here King
back the seven and Rook the C3 now
threatening check to pick up the pawn so
A5 rooked the C7 check King to F6 and
now Rook the C6 with King to G7 and Rook
the A6 ding just puts the rock behind
the pass Pawn as one always should Rook
the B2 checking F3 Rook to A2 defending
the pawn now just King to G3 ding says
I'm holding this to a draw uh try and
uh try and prove otherwise okay Pawn to
H5 Rook to A8 now we have Rook to A1 and
King to G2 we have Pawn to A4 uh if you
if you go King to F6 try and bring that
King into the game because you really
want to do that so the king defends the
pawn and the rule can become active ding
would immediately switch the attention
over to the H Pawn so you can't really
do that so A4 was played yeah with
rooked A5 and attacking the five Pawn
Now Pawn to F6 King to F3 Now Pawn to A3
with Rook to A6 not just King to F7 uh
King to E3 we have King to E8 now comes
King to E2 uh just uh you know awaiting
to see what happens uh you or if you
capture the F Pawn then Pawn to A2 is
winning of course there's no defense
against The Rook D1 check and then you
promote to a queen even if you put the
King on F3 it doesn't really matter
you're gonna play Rook to G1 and then of
course even if Rook here you're gonna
Queen and you're gonna have to give up
The Rook captures and captures so it's a
it's a trick but of course uh ding is
too strong a player to fall for that so
just King Day 2 King E7 with King to F3
and now Rook to A2 if he pushes the pawn
to E2 is just a very quick draw so of
course Nepal will try to milk this as
long as possible uh King to E3 ding now
down to five minutes uh on the clock and
he still needs to make three more moves
to reach the next time control and then
he finally gets increment Rook to A1
King E2 King F7 King to F3 and now Rook
to A2 with King to E3 this is the 60th
move and King the E7 nipple also now
reaches the second time control King F3
King to D7 Rook captures an F6 Nepal had
to try something in order not draw the
game on the spot now comes Rook the B2
Rook to A6 and now Rook the B3 with
check King to G2 now King to C7 and okay
now the king will finally reach the
white Rook uh and here we have King the
F1 you could also try something like F4
here but it would be very tricky for
example Ponte no I mean F4 was played
here if you play something like King to
F1 then King the B7 can be very annoying
because after Rook day 4 King to B6 and
now after King to G2 trying to waste
time King B5 and after Rook to A7 now
you play King to B4 and now the pawn is
defended The Rook can become active so
this would be very dangerous for ding so
that's why he found F4 F4 is the only
move that uh you know keeps the position
equal he captures an F4 and now Pawn to
E5 ding also starts advancing his pass
Pawn King to B7 Rook to A4 and now we
have King the C6 and now uh you could
capture but again a very very dangerous
stuff if King captures King it comes to
D5 now we're gonna have to go back in
captors here and um this would be much
much harder to hold it than just you
know keeping the tension Rook the A6
with checking B5 rookie seven King to B6
Rook day eight King to C5 and now just
Rook the A6 with King to B5 Rook to A7
King to B6 and The Rook to A8 ding just
um you know moving his work waiting to
see what Apple do king C6 Rook day6
tracking 37 King to F2 King to E7 King
to G2 rookie 2 and King death 2. here we
have King F uh Rook G3 King F1 Rook to
C3 King F2 Rook E3 King to G2 and King
to D7 we have King to F2 King to C7 and
now ding finally plays it pawn to E6 as
the the king is now too far away from
the Pawn King to d8 now Comes The Rook
to eat a rook the A7 preparing E7 with
Chuck uh so here King Day 8 and now just
King to G2 and there is really no more
um uh wait to push for nepo he has to
trade pawns here Rook captures and E6
was played Rook characters on A3 with
Rook the G6 with check and now King to F
uh two this would be a terrible way for
ding to blunder the game if you played
King to F3 then Rook G3 check blunders
The Rook away and of course there's no
way that that happens but there's always
you know a way that it happens I mean it
would be it would be a weird conclusion
to a World Series championship match but
okay King F2 of course ding doesn't
wander Rook to G4 we have rooked the A5
and now Rook captures on H4 the nipple
now up two pawns but it doesn't really
matter King F3 with King D7 Rook to F5
now with King the A6 and The Rook
captures on F4 here an apple captured
back root captures an F4 and he was in
this position on move 90 that nipple
ending agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here for those
of you who are interested how this might
have concluded after this captures uh
you will of course not win the pawn uh
or you will maybe win the pawn but the
chances are you will probably get
stalemated let's say Rook to G3 you're
gonna play Rook G5 King H3 H foreign
and G3 will just put the king in the
corner and now black doesn't have a
choice either he moves the king back
from the pawn or you push the pawn and
now it's draw by stalemate so that's how
the game would have concluded uh so yeah
that's it for the classical portion of
the World Chess Championship match uh
nipple I had a chance here ding tried
something he didn't really get anything
spectacular out of the opening he was
just burning time and uh it seems that
those it really does seem that uh you
know once uh nepo and his team
discovered those leeches files that dink
couldn't get a any sort of Advantage out
of the opening uh so you know we'll see
if he if he does better in the Rapids
because this was a quite a good
opportunity white pieces final game you
know just playing uh no risk and in the
end he was the one that was risking
defeat and if if we are to believe cese
uh there was that beautiful winning line
uh after uh Rook one to G3 was played
had Nepal fund Rook to B3 uh but yeah
really crazy stuff tomorrow we continue
and tomorrow we end we will see rapid uh
chess then we will see fast rapid chess
and in the end uh if it's not decided in
Rapid it will be decided in a blitz
playoff but it will not come to
Armageddon they agreed that okay we will
not decide World classical Champion by
an Armageddon game
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed a
bit of a tough one for for the last game
and a bit of a longer video so sorry
about that I would like to thank Kim
Tori Jensen Ola Anders Danielson uh GM
Thomas rusman Micah Kennedy and
vladislavusatenko for her contribution
to my channel thank you I want to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the conclusion of the World
Chess Championship uh well until it
concludes see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day